most people believe in the JFK
conspiracy theory this is five years ago
okay if you go up a little bit on the
percentage
yeah look at this young where we're at
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going right there so most
people leave JFK wasn't killed by Oswald
alone okay
61 percent
don't believe it and by the way it's no
difference between male or female 62 and
60. okay
56 of white believe others were involved
72 percent of Hispanics
76 percent of African Americans
College grads 52 percent no college
degree 65 percent so the age is 60 62
60. it doesn't matter Republicans
identical look at that
60 or 71 Independents think it's even
more so Independence are saying no I
think it's even more liquid look at
Clinton and Trump Democrats a little bit
less
that somebody else was involved Trump a
little bit more so this has got nothing
to do with politics people on both sides
are sitting there saying something
happened here why do we not know about
it now here's here's a uh here's a a
question for you
behind closed doors the people that are
protecting this story okay that that
wanted to stay the way it is which is a
one bullet you know the Magic Bullet
that's just it's what happens we gotta
stick to let's stop talking guys can you
guys stop doing these meetings and these
events like you're bothering us a little
too much your your pain
why do you think it's necessary for us
to know who did this and who was behind
us why is it necessary for us to know
why should we know why shouldn't we just
move on
well I believe it you know it's
important to know from
the fact that
I don't think we've had an honest
democracy since
if you if and what this has done as you
can see right there
I don't know if you probably have a
another graph of this the
Public's belief
in what the government is saying when
JFK took office was something like 75
percent
all right
today it's in the 20s and if you look at
the graph
the single year biggest drop
was 1964 when the warn report was issued
so I I don't see how you can have a
functioning democracy if you have that
much cynicism and about and and they've
done focus groups on this and an
unbelievable ninety percent of the
public believes that Kenny's
assassination caused a period of
depression and cynicism to take over the
country that had not really existed
before
I mean anecdotally that's exactly what
we heard when we were talking to people
that very that exactly what he just said
we heard a lot of people use that the
phrasing is a little different depending
who you talk to but a lot of folks said
they grew up with a lot of people I
talked to who were Witnesses or Alive at
that time
um you know and they would say I grew up
you know thinking that I need to I was
patriotic I care about my country you
know
um and they said that that whole period
shook their belief
in our country and for like I think a
lot of younger people
um you know I oh it's a different graph
now but uh I know that when I talk to
younger people I talk to high school
students I talk to college students and
we use actually the assassinations as
educating education tools to think about
careers things like that you know like
nursing photography things like the film
and a lot of them just assume that I
talk to you say oh yeah conspiracy it's
not a dirty word to them you know and
they just believe that that's just the
way things are
and it's more often than not so what all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
or black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]